my name is millet Romani I'm a graduate
student at the University of California
Irvine I do observational cosmology and
I use the welcome language to train
neural networks to look for
gravitational lenses which are very
precious as natural telescopes in the
field of cosmology
good morning everyone thank you so much
for coming here at such an early hour
my name is Milan I'm from the department
physics and astronomy from University of
california-irvine glad to see you here
so I do research in observational
cosmology and I'm going to spend most of
my time during the start telling you
what the problem is rather than telling
you how I solve it very easily with
Mathematica so first of all probably
most of you know what gravitation lenses
are for those of you who don't know when
you have a galaxy far away like this one
it looks very small and then you have a
very massive galaxy in front of it the
light from this one would get bent by
the gravitational field of this one and
before here's on earth and it magnifies
the image of this background galaxy and
you can see the equations that are
governing gravitational lenses so these
are this is a very powerful tool because
we can't build telescopes this powerful
and they are there for free we just have
to find them the background galaxies
would look like a few dots and our most
powerful telescopes and after after they
get mends they would look like arcs like
this image that you see over here right
so what's so hard about finding them
well these are my favorite numbers 10 to
the 11 is one of my favorite numbers so
when you get 10 to the 11 stars you form
a galaxy and the observable universe has
10 to the 11 galaxies in it so let me
tell you what that means if you have an
8-footer straw and and you look through
it and if you could see the same way
that Hubble Space Telescope's sees you
would see that image on the very right
this one filled with galaxies this was
pointed at one of the darkest
of the sky and you see thousands of
galaxies but most of them are not
important
for my research because they are very
tiny they're just like dots but the ones
in the in the foreground that are larger
are the ones that I'm looking for so the
galaxies that I look at in a1 so let me
tell you how many galaxies I have to go
through to look for gravitational lenses
so if you have one degree by one degree
so when a square degree you have quarter
of a million galaxies so quarter of a
million images that you have to go
through and people in the past you know
would look in regions that are highly
probable to have gravitational lenses or
they would ask you know people by the
like in projects like sitting scientists
and other projects like that ask people
to go through images and classify
galaxies and look for gravitational
lenses that was the technique so now we
are trying to make astronomy autonomous
because we have new telescopes coming
that are producing 10 terabytes of data
every night hundred try bytes of data
every night and we can't handle that
much information you know using manpower
we need to make things automated so just
to just letting you know how many school
degrees there are in the sky 41,000
that's very huge so just multiply in a
quarter of a million by that number and
you see how many galaxies we need to
classify all right so when you get these
images they look like this so this is a
cut out of a galaxy doesn't look like
much so one of the challenges that I had
to face was to you know you know
automated way change the contrast and
the gamma correction and all sorts of
things to make them you know look
something nice and it does
always work you know get these white
images local images and then there's a
really neat mathematical function that I
use I call it magic you click that and
you see the arc in that image so that's
the lens galaxy so if I didn't adjust
the contrast and the gamma correction
and the brightness correctly I would not
be able to see that and my code wouldn't
be able to see that so I use a histogram
transform and that works like magic so
in other areas of computer science they
just you know average the mean because
you need to send normalized data to your
neuron network but that doesn't work
here if you just normalize your data
they would you wouldn't see the arcs so
I use a histogram transform to make the
arcs to stand out and it works pretty
well so the problem is with neural
networks and machine learning you need
thousands of examples we do not have
thousands of examples of gravitational
lenses so I have to make them
artificially one of the methods I use is
this little applet here so I have a
collection of elliptical galaxies so
spiral galaxies usually don't form you
know lens systems it's elliptical
galaxies that do because they have more
Dark Matter by the way it's not the mass
of the stars that are causing the
lensing it is the dark matter that is
causing the lensing so it is very
important because we can understand Dark
Matter better so you know I can
randomize this thing and form different
lenses and if I like it I can restore it
and then do this I do this I have 200
times and then I I do image
augmentations rotate and flip them move
them around a little to increase that to
you know a few thousand and then the
other technique which I started using
after I created this start was drawing
so I found this website that you can
draw very similar to you know gravity
gravitational lenses very easily and
before this I use this you know hardware
software called lens tool which you have
to you know using Linux and you have to
code for it
and it's very slow and it gives you
perfect arcs that are that match you
know physics but that doesn't matter
it just has to match the geometry and
needs to look similar so this method
combined with the drawing method works
very fine for me to create these
examples of lenses and for the example
of nonlin says I have thousands of
examples I just you know select randomly
from the data I have right so a little
about the neural networks probably you
know about it you know you have
convolution neural networks these were
invented long time ago but we weren't
able to use them because of GPUs and you
have convolution layers pooling layers
and at the end you have fully connected
layers that are basically looking for
features in in images so my particular
neural network has this particular
architecture it took me a while to you
know find this one because if it's
larger than this it would take a long
time for me to scan the area that I have
which is just two square degrees right
to two degrees by two degrees it would
take you know hours on a GPU so I had to
optimize to the lowest number of layers
that I have you have any questions about
the layers convolution layers all right
all right so um you know yes
yes yes so if you don't have hyperbolic
tangent you usually use you know pretty
linear and then that's that's basically
cut off and I find that this is I think
looks like this
so it's sensitive to negative numbers as
well I mean you can't ship the bias but
so it is it it doesn't turn it into you
know zeros and non zeros so it gives it
more range and I think the reason it
works better in this case is because the
lenses so the arcs are a little dimmer
versus in you know cats and dogs you
have you know edges that are clear all
right so does this work yes so I was
able to find a few lenses and then I was
just testing this some of these lenses
were previously known and the way I find
them is not by asking is this a lens or
not it's by assigning a probability so I
assign a probability to quarter quarter
of a million images and then I rank them
so so I have two neuron networks rather
than one the first one puts all the
lenses in the top 5% the most probable
ones so that's already really good but
not really because that means I have to
look at 15,000 images which is still
very difficult so I have another one
which specializes in to filtering things
that look like lenses like your spiral
galaxies because they have these arcs
and some things that I'm like is that it
lends I'm not sure you know I still have
issues classifying them soft are not
clear and as you see you know some of
them do not have a counter image like
like this one you just have this arc and
then you don't know if this is a lens or
not and one of the issues that I have
here I'm not using color information I
did not have access to color information
which was
mistake but I have to finish this
project many have color information
these arcs look red and the foreground
looks blue so you can say ah that's a
that's a lens and if it's not it just
has the same color etc and sometimes you
get these nice you know lenses alright I
want to share with you a little story
about my hardware's so Nvidia was very
nice enough to give us a free GPU and my
advice was nice enough to buy me this
gorgeous external GPU enclosure so most
challenging to set it up but after you
know doing it for the first time it's
pretty easy you just plug it in to your
laptop and iconic your internet mouse
everything and then you just plug into
your laptop and then you have to you
have to install the drivers for that GPU
which we can get from Nvidia and you
have to do you have to get CUDA by
signing up on Nvidia etc and on
mathematical I had no problem all you
need to do it is to say after doing all
those things you need to say you know
it's CUDA link and then system
information so once you do that you go
to links and then you go to CUDA and
there you can see your GPUs so I had one
for my laptop and I had one which was my
external GPU because I really wanted to
know which one is reached when they are
using target device to train your neural
network so when you are training your
neural network
I think it's automatically set to CPU if
I'm not mistaking but then you can say
GPU one GPU two etc and you know it's
very faster GPUs are made well you're on
networks has to be applied on GPUs it
takes hunt so so running my code on a
GPU is 170 times faster than running it
on a CPU for instance right and you know
I like to thank NSF for supporting my
research Nvidia
the warm community for answering my
bizarre questions understand flow and
thank you so much if you have questions
I would be glad to answer so we do not
have those for four galaxies we do have
them for stars and it's not secret
diffraction patterns you get those
sometimes but it's mainly spikes that
extend many arc seconds and sometimes I
have images and there's a line going
through them and so I have to you know
filter result so only stars have those
and I had to kind of you know create
extra stars separate them rotate them
augment them to teach my neural network
that you know he shouldn't classify
stars as lenses so I showed you a few
examples there were well we wouldn't say
known we call them lens candidates
because you need to do a lot of research
to prove that they are actual lenses
sometimes they're obvious but for many
cases they are not so there were I think
six sealings candidates in the cosmos
field from Hubble Space Telescope and
then you know I was able to find
majority of them some of them far beyond
the window I'm looking and and many of
them did not look like lens galaxies and
they were lens galaxies but not in the
band I was looking at so in this color
space they wouldn't look like lenses at
all so after doing that they're like 50
that looked like lenses in that band and
then on top of that 50 I was able to
find an additional 12 or so
yes please
I forgot I was going to ask well what
was that the first one was do you know
how many brain cells do we have it's 10
to the 11 and I was yep
it didn't have anything to do with my
type but I like that number a lot yes so
that GPO I think has 3500 CUDA cores yes
yes it's a it's Titan XP sorry it's
Titan XP GTX time yeah yes
oh I started my research during learning
tensorflow
and then I got introduced to Kara's my
code was you know very long and then you
know become became smaller and then you
know Mathematica
released machine learning package and
then I wasted so much time it's pretty
easy yeah like everything is in a
notebook right now you know and and if
you want if you want to scan the entire
Skype you know I can do this test on
Mathematica and you know shift it to
tensor flow or pork you that way but I
don't see any reason because it's fast
enough so now it takes me 200 seconds to
scan quarter of a million images on that
GPU so that's doable does that answer
your question
a lot I would say maybe six months yeah
but you know the efficiency for
graduates is on that high because their
meetings or classes or other things so
that's probably why yes
I tried a lot of things so I had a
neuron network that would classify stars
in spiral galaxies elliptical galaxies
and all sorts of things I tried
different methods the best one that
networked was having two neuron networks
and then you have lens versus none lens
and and then you do that again but then
you know I take my training data
randomly from from the Cosmosphere from
these images so when you go to the
second so when I then I reduce quarter
of a million to only yes yes yes
they do they do but there are various
gifts so I'm not focusing on that yes
yes good question
so right now what I was trying to do was
a proof of concept which you know we
already need our 60 lenses here and want
to see if we can find them and without
using those in my training data and then
you know to scan them to find more
lenses which I'm gonna try you know in
an upcoming week is to use those those
lenses and and look for you know new
lenses see if I can't find anything but
you know after this one I'm moving to
new new fields and then you know you
have to you have to I think you have to
especially training around network for a
particle telescope for a party called
camera and possibly for a particular
filter for the color bands unless you
know there's a high contrast between
your your your arcs and your forego for
growing galaxies then possibly but you
know the resolution is very different
and the color space is very different so
I think you have to yeah I think so so
that the challenges are of my research
unfortunately it's not machine learning
is generating the data and you know I
used lens lens to I don't know if anyone
is familiar with that you're very
limited to what you can do it wasn't
designed to generate thousands of
examples I only gives you arcs and we
have to superpose that against galaxies
which I did that's why it took you know
six months for me to try that and there
aren't that many lenses that look like
that so later I figure that you can just
draw them that works perfectly fine just
to draw them now I have to find a nice
way of saying that in my paper but I
don't know what the referee would say
so when you run networks or in general
yes yes there are special software's
that do that I mean that's why we are
looking for them so I'm not doing that
part there is a another person in my
group that does just that because this
would help us understand devolution of
galaxies and then there's this really
cool thing which was first observed a
few years ago you have a supernova
happening in the background galaxy and
when that happens you know it's huge
because you get images of the supernova
in one arc first and then you get India
yet the second image later maybe a week
later maybe a month later and that helps
you to probe the cosmos and the dark
matter in between and then know the
distances is just really powerful so we
are trying to identify these lenses so
we you know we have telescopes that are
looking at the photon count basically
they count the photons and if we want to
see when they happen so we will shift
our telescopes to them because they're
very very precious to probe the cosmos
so that's another way of that you can
extract information and then you know
reconstructing those images helps you
understand the Dark Matter distribution
around the foreground galaxies and also
evolution of the galaxies because you
can see further back in time and the
space question
[Music]
you have to do a lot of hand waving and
endure you know some people are
concerned that there's some issues here
but yes because you know how much light
you have from the foregoing galaxy from
the background galaxy and then you know
what type organics is there you know
there you know red ship etc so you know
how much dark matter they should have
you know the relative distances so you
can kind of figure out how much dark
matter is around each one of them you
can but then you know you're relying on
one theory after another and then
suddenly you have you know 50 theories
back to back so that's kind of
concerning no no this is how it looks
this is this is a galaxy and there's
this uniform joint ball of dark matter
around it and this is how big the galaxy
is compared to that and that's why when
you look at the rotation curve of the
stars around the galaxies you know they
kind of go higher and higher and they
Plateau and it doesn't matter how far
away you go from the front center of the
galaxies the stars on the spirals and
the you know far ends of the galaxy are
rotating with the same speed that
doesn't make sense and that's that was
the first hint too dark matter and the
gravitational lenses or kind of the
proof that hey there's something going
on here
but yeah so even if you have you know 10
5 times 6 times more distant from the
center and the ones that you see on the
edge they seem moved with the same
orbital velocity around the galaxy
I think so the dynamic is the end the
fluid dynamic of galaxies very complex
and they just do simulations nowadays
rather than thinking about it works but
yeah I'm not an expert in that area but
I think so right thank you so much for
coming
[Applause]